Picture this.
Your friend and you are watching a sitcom...
...and a sassy sidekick walks into a room, carrying a four-tiered wedding cake.
He trips, falls, and face-plants into the cake.
Your friend doubles over with laughter and says,...
..."So ridiculous!"
"So ironic!"
Well, quick, what do you do?
Do you laugh along with the laugh track...
...and let this grievous misinterpretation of irony go,...
...or you throw caution to the wind and explain the true meaning of irony?
If you're me, you'd choose the latter.
Unfortunately, irony has been completely misunderstood.
We tend to throw out that term whenever we see something funny or coincidental.
And while many examples of true irony can be funny,...
...that is not the driving factor of being ironic.
A situation is only ironic if what happens is the exact opposite of what was expected.
If you expect A, but get B, then you have irony.
Let's take the slapstick cake situation as an example.
When someone walks in, precariously balancing something that shouldn't be carried alone,...
...trips, falls, and makes a mess,...
...it is funny, but it's not ironic.
In fact, you probably expect someone who is single-handedly carrying a huge cake to trip.
When he does, reality aligns with expectations,...
...and so that is not irony.